HERE CLEARLY EVOLVES DAILY.
>> Bill: THANK YOU, WE’LL BE IN
TOUCH THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
WE’LL BRING IN THE REPUBLICAN
SENATOR FROM WEST VIRGINIA.
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT A CRISIS.
THE ADMINISTRATION WON’T USE
THAT WORD.
WHAT DO YOU CALL IT?
>> IF THIS ISN’T A CRISIS I
DON’T KNOW WHAT IS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS PROJECTING 117,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDER.
FEBRUARY WAS THE LARGEST MONTH
EVER.
AND WE’RE HOLDING THESE
CHILDREN WITH DHS LONGER THAN
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE HELD.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE?
I CERTAINLY FEEL OUTRAGE.
I THINK IT IS A DIRECT RESULT
OF THE SIGNALING AND POLICIES
THAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE WILL
PUT INTO PLACE.
>> Dana: SO I THINK YOU’VE BEEN
IN TOUCH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BEEN TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO TRY TO TAKE THIS
ON?
THEY WANT TO GET THE COVID
RELIEF BILL THROUGH BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THERE IS SOMETHING
HAPPENING THAT THEY PROBABLY
DON’T WANT TO PAY AS MUCH
ATTENTION TO BUT IT IS
HAPPENING REGARDLESS.
>> IT IS HAPPENING.
YOU HEAR THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS,
THE ISSUE OF THEM COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, COVID TESTING AND
RELEASING THEM TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
WE’RE REACHING A POINT WHERE WE
SEE A LOT OF GOOD PROGRESS
BEING MADE ON THE COVID FRONT
AND NOW IF I WAS THE GOVERNOR
OF TEXAS I WOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
THE THING ABOUT IT IS THE
OUTRAGE WE’VE HEARD OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS WAS ALL ABOUT
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING HELD
FOR TOO LONG AND FOR EXTENDED
PERIOD EVER TIME.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
THE NUMBERS ARE EVEN BIGGER.
SO THE WHITE HOUSE CERTAINLY
HAS SEEN A RED FLAG HERE.
>> Bill: ON COVID WILL YOU VOTE
YES OR NOT?
>> I’M VOTING NO, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Bill: HOW COME?
>> BILL, THE PACKAGE IS JUST
BLOATED WITH A TRILLION DOLLARS
OF EXTRANEOUS ITEMS NOT FOR THE
TARGETED EMERGENCY RELIEF THAT
THE 10 OF US REPUBLICANS WENT
TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO OFFER.
WE SEE THE NUMBERS TODAY.
THE ECONOMY IS RECOVERING.
MORE PEOPLE ARE WORKING.
THERE STILL IS A LOT OF HELP TO
BE DONE AND CERTAINLY ON THE
HEALTH SIDE AND ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT SIDE.
WE WERE WILLING AND READY TO GO
THERE.
BUT WHEN WE HAVE ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS IN THERE TO THE
TUNE OF A TRILLION DOLLARS
THAT’S A NON-STARTER FOR ME.
>> Dana: ONE OF YOUR FELLOW
SENATORS FROM ALASKA TOLD THIS
TO "POLITICO", I CAN SAY I
DON’T WANT TO HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH IT.
INSTEAD I HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE IF IT IS
GOING TO PASS ARE THERE  WAYS
IT CAN BE SHAPED.
AS THE AMENDMENTS PUT FORWARD
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD PUT
FORWARD THAT COULD PASS OR ARE
WE LOOKING AT A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION THAT NO REPUBLICANS
WILL BE ABLE TO GET SOMETHING
CHANGED IN THIS BILL?
>> I DON’T THINK WE’RE
NECESSARILY ON THE AMENDMENT
PROCESS LOOKING AT A FOREGONE
CONCLUSIONS.
TWO THINGS I WILL TRY TO AMEND
IS EXPAND THE USE OF THESE
DOLLARS FOR BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT IN RURAL AMERICA.
THERE IS NO SPECIFIC BROADBAND
DOLLARS IN HERE.
THAT’S A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
THE OTHER THING IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE GET READY TO DO A BIG
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE.
LET’S USE THOUGH OF THESE
DOLLARS TO FILL THE GAP WE
ALWAYS HAVE WITH THE GAS TAX TO
PAY FOR THIS.
SO I THINK THERE AGAIN ANOTHER
BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
I’M NOT PIE IN THE SKY TO THINK
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES BUT IF WE CAN
IMPROVE IT, I THINK WE SHOULD.
>> Bill: A COUPLE OF THINGS.
SHARP QUESTIONS HERE.
WILL ANY REPUBLICAN VOTE FOR
THE $2 TRILLION BILL IN THE
SENATE?
>> YESTERDAY WAS A GOOD
INDICATION THAT NO REPUBLICAN
WILL VOTE FOR IT.
I THINK YOU DON’T KNOW AT THE
END.
>> Bill: ON WHICH BILL OR WHAT
IS THE FIRST BILL UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHERE A
REPUBLICAN SENATOR WILL VOTE
WITH DEMOCRATS?
>> THAT’S THE BIG
DISAPPOINTMENT HERE, BILL.
WE HAVE HAD FIVE BIPARTISAN
COVID PACKAGES.
THIS WAS THE PERFECT BILL TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE COUNTRY THAT
WE CAN AND WILL WORK TOGETHER
AND WE HAVE THE BEST INTENTIONS
TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS PANDEMIC
ISSUE.
THIS WAS WHERE WE SHOULD HAVE
JOINED TOGETHER.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL HERE.
THIS IS AN AREA WE’VE WORKED
TOGETHER BEFORE.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING WE CAN DO
TOGETHER AGAIN.
>> Bill: HE PREACHED UNITY
INAUGURATION DAY.
>> RIGHT.
I’VE BEEN IN THE OVAL OFFICE
TWICE AND HE SAYS THE SAME
THING.
HE SEEMS WILLING TO NEGOTIATE.
>> Dana: AND HIS STAFF IS NOT?
>> I THINK FORCES PUSHING HIM
ARE STRONGER THAN THAT WHA* HIS
NATURAL INKLIN INDICATIONS ARE.
HE WANTS TO DEAL BUT DOESN’T
FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE WANTS
TO.
>> Dana: HE IS THE PRESIDENT.